voici l'une des rares écoles françaises
où l'on forme des i même en plein coeur
du morvan
sofiane à 23 ans vient de belgique
son rêve devenir imam et mener la prière
la pratique c'est plutôt ici quand vous
avez vu aujourd'hui à la mosquée un
étudiant qui dirige la prière c'est un
humain bon voilà simplement dirigé des
prières de temps en temps les prêches du
vendredi c'est des élèves qui les
dispensent sofiane et sur la première de
ses trois années de formation
pour l'instant beaucoup de théories
secours par exemple sur les textes
sacrés de l'islam
ici les enseignants sont conscients
devenir imam c'est aussi devoir faire
face à un fléau la radicalisation
le but c'est qu'ils transmettent c'est
que eux après arrive à déconstruire
justement le discours de certains
extrémistes etc
c'est le but c'est que eux plus tard
fasse ce travail là dans les mosquées
là où ils vont enseigner dans cet
institut 200 personnes apprennent
l'arabe prennent des cours de théologie
ils viennent de france de belgique du
royaume uni et dans ce cours de 3e année
on parle du coran mais aussi de
l'actualité et des réseaux sociaux
vous avez déjà vu un juge comme ça non
tous arrivent à la fin de leur formation
dans moins d'un an
certains pourront devenir imam dans une
mosquée française avec toutes les
difficultés qui en découlent ont
malheureusement des fois on a des gens
qui vont pas dans les mosquées ils vont
sur internet ils sont bourrés par des
informations qui viennent d'ailleurs et
des fois ça peut dégénérer arriver à des
drames comme suit former convenablement
pour pouvoir convaincre une personne qui
à ces genres de idée des professionnels
formés dans notre pays
adapté à la loi et au contexte français
c'est ce que demande emmanuel macron qui
a annoncé la création d'un label de
formation
pour les imams
[Musique]